bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro de check up votre
magazine santé bien-être ce mois ci nous
nous penchons sur un service assez
méconnu dans les hôpitaux la commission
des relations avec les usagers au
sommaire également la situation des
cabinets de groupe médicaux un cri
d'alarmé a été lancé par l'union
régionale des professionnels de santé
d'île de france
mais tout d'abord place aux premiers
sujets en ce début d'été certes le
soleil a été plutôt discret pour autant
les vacances ont commencé pour certains
et il est bon de rappeler que les rayons
ultra violets ne sont pas sans danger
pour notre santé comment bien protéger
sa peau quels sont les bons conseils
toutes les réponses avec le dermatologue
patrick filet
bonjour patrick fille l'aise alors en
cette période d'été de vacances le
soleil est au rendez vous comment
protéger sa peau tout en bronzant les
vêtements c'est la meilleure protection
ensuite bien sûr surtout tête chez les
adultes vêtements aussi chez les adultes
mais également bien sûr on a des crèmes
solaires si on a les yeux bleus la peau
très très clair on est quasiment roues
ou si on n'aime pas très mat on choisira
bien sûr pas le même type de crème
solaire des réponses très claires vont
choisir des indices tu élevé les peaux
mates vont choisir des indices plus
faible et il ya un an s'élevait du coup
ce sont ceux sur lesquels indice élevé
ces 30 50 ou si on a vraiment des
espèces d'allergie sollers et aux 50
plus qu'on appelle maintenant et puis
sinon on peut descendre à 10 1 10 nice
par exemple un indice de 10 les indices
de protection sont calculés en fonction
de d'une quantité standardisée de 2 mg
par centimètre carré c'est énorme
personne ne fait ça et on tout le monde
mais c'est plutôt un milligramme au
moins que l'on s'applique déjà
badigeonnez voilà c'est quand on a des
50 c'est comme si on avait un design
c'est finalement déjà au départ en plus
les crèmes solaires ne restent pas toute
la journée ne soit pas efficace toute la
journée en fonction de son activité même
de manière générale est des activités
d'eau qu'il faut se badigeonner
plusieurs fois par jour effectivement
pour une certaine efficacité à quelle
fréquence alors que ça dépend si on
avait sonné et celtique le pot si on a
une maladie ou pas mais on va dire
toutes les deux trois heures me faut le
refaire mais faut le refaire quels sont
les facteurs de risque si vous avez des
mélanomes les grains de beauté cancéreux
le batteur de russie la peau très claire
les roues un les gens font des photos
type 2 comme on dit des gens qui ont
beaucoup de grains de beauté c'est un
facteur de risque des gens qui ont de
leurs familles ont déjà eu un cancer de
peau mélanome un minibus cancéreux un
train beauté cancéreux c'est des gens
qui ont des les enfants la famille peut
avoir des facteurs génétiques également
et c'est ça les principaux facteurs de
risque et surtout les vins le coup de
soleil de l'enfance est également un
facteur de risque très important de
conserver d'attraper un cancer de peau
est ce que quand on est dans l'eau est
ce que le fait de se baigner peut
permettre d'éviter les coups de soleil
non non vous vous rafraîchissez donc
effectivement vous avez moins chaud mais
quand vous sortez de l'eau il faut vous
essayez les petites gouttelettes qui
reste quand on se laisse sécher des
petites gouttelettes fondouk il voit sa
frappe est plus facilement des coups de
soleil ou séchés c'est l'agréable mais
il doit travailler plus facilement des
coûteux l'aï donc effectivement non
l'eau et un mauvais non ça va pas c'est
un piège en cas c'était exactement très
bien quelles sont les conséquences d'un
trop plein de soleil et de comportements
excessifs par rapport au soleil voilà
d'où l'intérêt de plusieurs donc déjà le
virus à pau donc on a plus de rides
c'est largement démontré c'est sûr à
100% et puis bien sûr tous les types de
cancer de peau qu'on peut attraper donc
les coups de soleil qui peuvent induire
des mélanomes arrivant de beauté
cancéreux ou le soleil chronique un
petit peu donc comme par exemple les
marins les agriculteurs les gens qui
travaillent à l'extérieur ou un autre
type de cancer de peau parce que il
n'attrape pas que le soleil la peau
tannée un petit peu par le soleil mais à
traves d'autres petits type de cancer de
peau un peu moins grave peut-être mais
qu'il faut opérer enfin ça fait les
cicatrices train voilà donc
préparer sa peau au soleil est-ce que
selon vous c'est vraiment efficace
alors ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que les
dégâts liés au soleil sont cumulatifs
toute sa vie c'est à dire que si vous le
soleil que vous apprenez vous avez pris
à 20 ans vous vous en aurez toujours les
effets sur votre peau à 60 ans donc
préparer sa peau entre guillemets en
allant faire en allant se mettre au
soleil à la piscine je dirais plutôt ou
dans son jardin sur nana finalement on
sait qu'on se rajoutent des facteurs de
risque on se rajoutent du soleil si de
toute façon lui va se cumuler au soleil
des vacances donc c'est pas c'est pas
très sain c'est comme si on disait je
fume à midi mais pour préparer un film
et à vide et j'ai fini à 2006 garrett à
l'isr
donc c'est pas bon c'est logique c'est
pas logique de se mettre au soleil avant
les vacances c'est pas logique bon
rassurez nous le soleil a quand même des
effets bénéfiques sur notre organisme en
tout cas un visage modéré et voilà je me
dirai très bien ça fait plaisir donc
c'était un élément important le problème
de la vitamine d pas très très vraie
impasse et pas besoin on n'a pas besoin
d'aller en vacances pour la vitamine d
il suffit d'avoir dix minutes de soleil
pour le visage et les avant-bras et ça
suffit voyons pas besoin de ça met une
heure au soleil c'est pas la peine pour
la vienne pour un version stock de
vitamine d renouveler chaque jour donc
validé on réalise plus on c'est pas un
vrai critère mais disons voilà il faut
se faire plaisir aussi mais il faut se
faire plaisir en faisant attention pape
abîmé sa peau pour le futur c'est pas
pareil que la luminothérapie savez on
donne pour les dépressifs pas ça ça
passe par la lumière visible et ça passe
par les yeux c'est pas là c'est pas
comme les uv on va vous regrettez vous
voyez c'est pas la même chose du tout
hein donc le bien-être avec le bronzage
fait plus parce qu'on est content d'en
faire reposer c'est plutôt s'appeler
finalement une retail piscine peut être
qu'on aurait même bien d'être peut-être
mais en tout cas voilà le bronzage
foster plaisir aussi merci patrick
filasse pour tous vos conseils c'est moi
qui vous remercie merci bonne journée
c'est un organe dont on parle peu dans
les hôpitaux la commission des relations
avec les usagers
l'association ufc que choisir de
versailles vient d'intégrer celle de
deux établissements du département
l'occasion pour nous de se pencher sur
le rôle de cette commission julia de
pouce on est lundi moines pour les
images
l'association ufc que choisir de
versailles vient d'obtenir l'accord pour
intégrer le comité des usagers de deux
nouveaux établissements l'hôpital privé
de l'ouest parisien de trappes et la
clinique des franciscaines de versailles
ces comités appelé également commission
de la relation avec les usagers et de la
qualité de la prise en charge médicale
permettent aux patients d'exprimer leurs
difficultés il s'agit après une
commission donc d'experts de veiller à
la défense des droits des usagers dans
les hôpitaux on examine si vous voulez
tout ce qui a trait à la qualité des
soins dire par exemple l'accueil des
malades les délais d'attentes le confort
d
des balades aussi les droits par exemple
le ticket modérateur tout ce qui
concerne l'environnement sous lé des
soins au sein de cette commission qui se
réunit régulièrement le représentant
légal de l'hôpital le médiateur médecin
le médiateur non médecins et deux
représentants des usagers tous astreints
au secret professionnel l' ufc que
choisir participe depuis huit ans déjà
aux réunions de l'hôpital mignot de
versailles grâce à cela des mesures ont
été prises dans le domaine des urgences
par exemple on avait vu des personnes
par exemple qui resté assez longtemps
cent cinq ans s'occupe d'elle et donc
grâce à notre action par exemple on a
obtenu que une infirmière passe
et regarde si la personne toutes les
heures passent et la personne sont
absentés n'empire pas facile à rassurer
la réconforter lorsqu'on interroge les
usagers la majorité n'a jamais entendu
parler de ces comités institué depuis
2002 mais quand on leur explique qu'ils
y voient une réelle nécessité je trouve
que c'est vachement pratique et parce
que quand même quand on va à l'hôpital
n'a pas beaucoup à renseignements au
fait même au téléphone quand on n'a pas
les hôpitaux on ne donne toujours pas
beaucoup de renseignements donc et
parfois on rate les choses en fait
importante donc ça peut nous aider bat
déjà mis leur les services à l'hôpital
et nous aider quand des usagers en fait
parce que nous on a toujours besoin de
formation bas je pense que ça dépend des
hôpitaux et que le problème c'est le
monde c'est pas forcément les médecins
ou les aides soignantes je sais pas à
quoi c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de
monde donc ça va être très dur à gérer
après je m'en faisais surtout un suivi
psychologique qu'il faut vraiment mettre
en place le comité rencontre de ces
analyses et propositions dans un rapport
présenté au conseil de surveillance de
l'hôpital ce dernier délibère alors sur
les mesures à adopter afin d'améliorer
la qualité de l'accueil et de la prise
en charge des patients
l'union régionale des professionnels de
santé a lancé un cri d'alarmé concernant
la situation des cabinets de groupe
médicaux exemple à voisins le bretonneux
un médecin nous explique les difficultés
qu'ils rencontrent
aucune secrétaire à l'accueil juste une
chaise vide c'est l'une des conséquences
des difficultés rencontrées par ce
cabinet de groupe médical à
voisins-le-bretonneux alors qu'elle
était quatre auparavant la dernière
secrétaire sera licencié au 1er juillet
en cause des charges financières trop
lourdes dans le cabinet certains
médecins vont partait en retraite et un
seul départ suffit à fragiliser le
groupe parce que les autres médecins qui
ont déjà du mal à assurer les charges
n'arrive plus à
vous pouvoir assumer les charges
financières qui deviennent trop lourdes
d'après une étude de l'ue est repéré
s'il de france près de 30 % des médecins
exerçant en groupe ont plus de 60 ans
l'exercice libéral n'attirerait plus du
tout les jeunes médecins pour une simple
raison l'évolution des mentalités je
crois que les mentalités ont changé à
partir du moment où s'est installée une
politique des 35 heures en france alors
bien sûr les médecins ne sont pas
prendre cinq heures mais les jeunes
médecins actuelle refuse totalement de
consacrer
70 heures par semaine à leur travail ils
souhaitent améliorer leur qualité de vie
pouvoir avoir une vie de famille ce qui
n'était pas toujours le cas de nos
générations à nous c'est l'une des
raisons essentielles
ce cabinet a voisins le bretonneux n'est
pas un cas isolé toujours d'après une
étude de l'ue rbs 80% des cabinets de
groupe médicaux d'ile-de-france sont
fragilisées et à terme dans les trois
ans quarante pour cent de ces cabinets
serait menacé de fermeture selon le
médecin les difficultés serait aussi lié
aux contraintes administratives qui
pèsent sur la profession et les
conséquences pourraient être très
importantes
il ya un risque réel de voir disparaître
une offre de soins dans des régions où
si
proches que celles de versailles
rambouillet où la moyenne d'âge des
médecins est très très élevé et où le
remplacement ne se fait pas sur waza
même
j'ai appris
le départ très proche
d'un des médecins qui ne pas pas en
retraite mais qui fuit l'exercice
libéral pour se réfugier dans un
exercice des salariés beaucoup plus
confortable sans apporter de blâme ce
confrère
et si les cabinets sont moins nombreux
d'après lui les patients se dirigerait
plus dans les hôpitaux au risque de les
encombraient encore davantage une des
solutions qu'il évoque la mise en place
des contrats aidés pour les cabinets
médicaux bien qu'il soit passionné par
son métier ce médecin à 68 ans et
quarante années d'exercice aimerait bien
trouver un jour un successeur
c'est que c'est terminé merci de nous
avoir suivis je vous souhaite un
excellent été à tous